okay this video is going to be an
overview of par pulo and friston's 2022
active inference textbook chapter 10
active inference as a unified theory of
sentient Behavior I'll read the quote
and then Ali please feel free to give
your first overview take on the chapter
in general we are least aware of what
our minds do best Marvin Minsky so what
is chapter 10
about
okay so chapter 10 is by far my uh most
favorite chapter in the whole book but
uh uh at the same time uh it differs
from all the other chapters um in the
sense that it tries to connect connect
active inference to so many other
disciplines and also uh provides uh some
kind of unifying themes in order to tie
many of the looser strands uh of the
theoretical work that's been done so far
at least until um um I mean the books
publication so it's a pretty pretty uh
enticing chapter in terms of um I mean
providing uh many promising uh or
introducing some
um future research um trajectories or at
least promising research uh trajectories
for future so uh for anyone who wants to
pursue active influence research I
believe this particular chapter here can
provide uh I mean quite a bit bit of uh
interesting ideas to
pursue yes this will just be a quick
overview they're going to connect a lot
of dots they abstract away from the
specific active inference generative
models discussed in previous chapters
and focus on integrative aspects of the
framework which as Ali mentions is one
of the most exciting and motivating and
inspiring
Parts we're going to find out by the end
of the chapter whether we have what we
sought after a unified perspective on
problems like perception action
selection attention and emotion
regulation all these topics which are
studied with obviously a diversity of
methods but also on the theoretical side
essentially in commiserate Frameworks
and so active inference here is being
positioned as a way to integrate across
these different cognitive phenomena and
on the more historical or philosophical
side how established theories like
cybernetics idea motor theory of action
reinforcement learning and optimal
control can also be understood within
the integrative stance that active
inference
provides section 10.2 wrapping up is
like a speedrun on the book itself they
Summarize chapter one active inference
as a normative approach a chapter with a
lot of similarities to chapter 10
chapter two the low road to active
inference how basian
statistics chapter three the high road
to active inference the free energy
principle and the imperative to
exist chapter four the formal aspects of
active inference with a focus on
variational inference on generative
models chapter 5 they developed from the
abstract perspective in chapter
4 and went into more detail on the
process theory about how the principle
may be implemented by the brain and they
gave a bunch of examples of systems of
interest and related work on the Maman
nervous system chapter six the recipe to
design active inference model chapter
six kicks off the second half of the
book and takes a pragmatic turn towards
Hands-On application Learners building
their own generative models along the
way chapters seven and eight are very
curtly summarized here this pair of
chapters describes the continuous in
chapter eight and discreet in chapter
seven generative models and chapter nine
on empirical modelbased analysis looks
at how to connect data to generative
models so any comments on that or
continue on with section 103 connecting
the
dots I think we can go on to chapter to
section 10.3 because uh you provided the
basic summary of section 10.2 perfectly
thanks so what about 10
three okay so 103 um is about going
Beyond some uh specific uh aspects of um
I mean cognitive facilities of of the
agents and try to uh somehow uh
integratively model uh the different sub
systems of um cognitive facil of the of
uh the particular agents um cognition uh
so for for instance we can model memory
attention perception and uh all all of
these uh different aspects of cognition
um in this integrated uh formula
of active inference within this
integrated formalism of active inference
and try to uh somehow see the
relationships between all of these uh
different aspects of cognition and I
believe uh this uh integrative work can
provide um many
Illuminating uh insights about how
various aspects of uh given agents
cognition is related to each other which
is I believe a very important open
question in cognitive psychology as
well great and the first paragraph
references
this direction in cognitive science
which is rather than to develop a simple
or Advanced model of one cognitive
phenomena separated out from the others
the suggestion of Daniel dennet in 1978
was to model a whole iguana a complete
cognitive creature perhaps a simple one
but 103 reiterates the way that active
inference can be used to connect dots
and integrate across cognitive phenomena
okay 104 predictive brains predictive
minds and predictive processing what
would you say about
this uh all right so this is also a
recurring question uh among the people
who uh who were introduced to active
inference for the very first time um
namely what is uh the distinction
between active inference and all the
other uh related theoretical Frameworks
such as predictive uh predictive
processing predictive coding and so on
and uh this partic this section uh gives
some hint about uh the similarities and
also the differences uh between all of
these uh different approaches and how
they relate to each other whether
they're subset um subset of
one one of each other or they're
distinctly different uh and
fundamentally different from each other
so um this this section here
10.4 um I believe can be helpful to
anyone who wants to understand how
active inference fits into this um
General framework of recent predicted
um predictive way of doing uh cognitive
psychology
research great and one nice quote
here active inference creatures fulfill
two imperatives epistemic and
pragmatic that's in reference to the
expected free
energy all right Section 105
perception okay so if we remember from
uh chapter 10 uh we were introduced to
active inference first by observing how
it can model uh the phenomenon uh
perception of of an agent um as opposed
to uh modeling its action and then we
saw that they're basically uh I mean uh
they mirror uh image of each other uh
the equations that describe those uh
phenomenon uh are basically the same
equations but
just flipped for um the situation we
want to model and
here uh there's this generalization of
how to um how how does it mean to model
perception as opposed to uh action and
in particular uh what's the basian brain
uh hypothesis um I mean what is uh the
particular approach taken by basian
brain hypothesis uh for modeling uh
perception as opposed to some uh other
conventional um approaches um to model
the same
phenomena great 105 perception flows
into 10 six action control so these two
sections
describe the perception and
action view of active inference in this
action Theory there's subsections on
idea motor theory which is a theory with
a long history that relates to how
cognition influences action cybernetics
active inference is closely related to
cybernetic
ideas and optimal control theory another
framework for thinking
about action
selection these sections differentiate
some distinctions of active inference
and optimal control theory cybernetics
and IDE motor theory however largely as
their systems of Interest tend to be
overlapping there's more in common with
these approaches that students of them
will find quite familiar in active
inference but again the authors take
care to distinguish what active
inference does differently than these
approaches as well anything else to add
there um nothing in particular thanks
all right 107 utility in decision-
making action expresses priorities
Mahatma
Gandhi uh okay so here in this section
there's also uh this kind of comparative
analysis between uh active inference
Theory and uh many
various a few U different approaches uh
used in machine learning so for instance
uh we have uh reinforcement learning
uh and um I mean various ways of doing
um modeling the planning and decision
making such as uh the general basian
decision Theory uh which is a super set
of many different approaches used to
model uh the decision making process
using basian inference uh and um also
there's this planning as inference which
is something uh that active inference
emphasizes uh uh as again as opposed to
some other traditional or conventional
uh way of modeling decision making
because
here as it I mean it's not just simple
planning uh as a consequence of uh
inference but uh but I mean planning
itself is uh considered um I mean the
inference uh considered itself as way of
uh constructing the U expected free
energy uh so uh in this way we can
regard planning as inference itself so
um this is one of the Novelties of
active
inference uh compared to any other
approaches as also explicitly stated on
page
all right 108 behavior and bounded
rationality okay so uh this section
also uh points to some interesting work
um with regards to how we can model um
different conceptions of rationality and
specifically uh bounded rationality and
um there are some interesting papers uh
which um came out after the publication
of uh this book uh in
which some some researchers uh pursue
this line of research um in order to U
model uh even the cons the way people
believe conspiracy theories or the way
people
uh do or make uh apparently irrational
decisions and uh they manifest some
irrational behavior and so on uh so uh
this
section points out uh to some tentative
ways that active inference can be
employed to model uh rationality as well
so it's not just about uh modeling
perception and action which is a
wellestablished way of uh doing AC
inference using active inference but
from this section onwards uh we uh
gradually move towards some Uncharted
territories uh which uh I mean
admittedly some of them are still uh at
their very nent stages
so
awesome section 109 veilance emotion and
motivation
okay again uh as I already mentioned uh
this is also one of the recent
developments of active inference how to
model uh emotion with act within active
inference framework so I believe uh one
of the uh earlier one of the earliest
papers that um did this kind of modeling
was uh
I forgot the title
but it's a way of um um of modeling uh
an a an agent's behavior in terms of uh
the positive or negative veence uh and
uh which directly reflects the emotional
state of that agent so by agent uh it
doesn't necessarily mean a human agent
but we can see that this kind of balance
in terms of positive and negative
balance and how it can uh motivate the
behavior of the agent uh can be captured
with uh within active inference
framework
using um using the same techniques we've
seen uh for epistemic foraging and so on
so uh it's an interesting way of
connecting
those two
subdisciplines yeah I think it's deeply
felt affect there's other related words
yes that was
it again another sort of complex or
composite life phenomena moving from
emotion onto homeostasis allostasis
interceptive processing this section
conveys work from variety of authors
that's been continued on about
homeostasis and allostasis which is the
anticipatory steering towards preferred
States and section 1011 attention
salience and epistemic Dynamics again
approaching a sort of cognitive
phenomena
Nexus and differentiating similar with
rule learning causal inference and fast
generalization here moving slightly more
towards the computational cognitive
side anything to say on those sections
1012 1011 or
1010 uh I just wanted to point to uh the
way that uh some so up to this point
we've seen uh mostly uh the application
oriented research of active inference uh
in order to deal with u various sorts of
scenarios uh I mean from modeling uh the
very basic uh cognition of um sentient
agents to uh modeling some even social
and cultural phenomena uh but I just
wanted to point to some uh interesting
theoretical work uh that's been going on
in parallel with these uh application
oriented Works uh which I believe can
open up even uh more uh opportunities
and uh probably even
uh I mean
drastically change the view of active
inference um in terms of how to how to
approach uh different scenarios and
different uh phenomena um so uh yeah
this kind of philosophical and
theoretical uh aspect active inference
uh
although it's still in its early stages
um is beginning to uh lead to some very
interesting results uh in terms of
applicability of active
inference awesome and then section
1013 active inference and other fields
open directions as the title would seem
to set off this section
goes into some of the extensions and
elaborations that are quite ongoing in
active inference especially related to
Social and cultural Dynamics and machine
learning and Robotics so subsection one
social cultural Dynamics subsection two
machine learning and
Robotics anything to say on that
section uh nothing other than uh there
are lots of uh interesting uh um
interesting development in this in these
uh particular domains uh especially
after uh I mean the explosion of llms
and generative AI uh we can see the
application of uh active inference even
to uh these Cutting Edge u u
technological developments as
well oh and then section 1014 summary
over read the Lord of the Rings quote
and then look forward to your take on
this last section home is behind the
world ahead and there are many paths to
tread through Shadows to the edge of
night until the stars are all a
light great so uh obviously this is the
last chapter of the whole book and uh
personally for me uh reading through
this book uh I mean reading reading it
multiple times uh have always been uh I
mean an increasingly enjoyable Journey
for me so each time uh I look at I mean
different sections and different uh
chapters of the book uh I I feel that
there are lots of um interesting
potentialities uh that can be uh pursued
further to uh and probably perhaps even
lead to some uh I don't know some
spin-off
theories and um some uh Branch to some
interesting new Fields uh that is
related to active inference but uh they
somehow begin to follow the life of
their own so uh the uh the main uh
strength of this book in my opinion is
exactly in providing uh these uh kind of
U nent ideas to develop further uh and
uh this is in my opinion uh one of the
main indicators of a great book uh which
uh I mean much more than trying to
answer the questions it provides some
fertile questions uh in the mind of the
reader great points totally concur time
and time again we've delighted in this
work it's a two paragraph section the
first paragraph is worth reading from we
started this book by asking whether it
is possible to understand brain and
behavior from first principles we then
introduced active inference as a
candidate Theory to meet this challenge
we hope that the reader has been
convinced that the answer to our
original question whether it's possible
to understand brain and behavior from
first principles is yes we know it side
there
on how do you feel and then the second
paragraph is a quite direct perforation
of the fourth
wall and they make a really
pragmatic day-to-day point about our
lives as people learning and applying
active inference which is it is
important to emphasize that active
inference is not something that can be
learned purely in theory we encourage
anyone who has enjoyed this book to
think about pursuing it in
practice important writes a passage in
theoretical neurobiology and eventually
so many other fields too are trying to
write down a generative model
experiencing the frustration when
simulations misbehave and learning from
violations of your prior belief when
something unexpected happens and this is
something that comes up all the time
there's so many incredible highflying
philosophical questions and in the
abstract quite philosophical they are
however once there's a generative model
on the table once chapter six has been
engaged with a lot of times the
abstractions and
generalizations are left out and you can
actually say well how is attention being
dealt with in this generative model or
what other way could it be done and so
making the generative model is a huge
moment and they emphasize that that's
how you can learn by doing but it's not
the only way that you can pursue and
engage active inference dayto day it
could be in the time interval that's
subliminal and between
iades it could be having what you expect
and prefer for dinner it could be
allostasis embedded extended enacted and
cultured allostasis and the authors are
confident which is to say precise in
their beliefs that we will continue to
pursue active inference in some form any
closing thoughts on 10
ali uh I just wanted to attest um to the
last sentence of the book uh because uh
definitely after U getting uh familiar
uh more and more with different aspects
of active inference I can see it um I
mean realized or uh or to uh to say it
in a better terms I can see it relevant
uh to many many different aspects of
life not just uh empirical or scientific
research but every aspect of
life awesome all right well thank you
for watching this overview video or
playlist and we hope to see you engaged
in a textbook group thank
you
thanks